[Applause]
thank you people i love it
love you for doing it
coming in here i know i wish i could use
my catchphrase
i know why you're happy but i can't even
today i mean this is a week where you
know we found out that the former
president almost pulled off his coup
by using the justice department of the
country itself and that's not even the
worst news we had
uh
the supreme court has been very busy
this week
today they overturned roe versus wade so
no reaction okay uh
well if you're keeping score at home
it's guns one women nothing
because they also
it's funny on a very weak very day i
think where the congress finally passed
i think the first gun control law in 30
years
well
the supreme court said hold my beer
[Laughter]
because they struck down a new york law
about carrying guns you know on your
body when you leave the house so
everyone now can be strapped at all
times in public
wow well welcome to right wing america
where if you want to end a young life
you have to shoot them
uh
but i gotta
i gotta give it to the conservatives
they always got this the supreme court
is the prize they keep their eye on the
prize right i mean first merrick garland
that whole thing with mcconnell then
trump gets in office trump appoints
three of these justices were appointed
by trump trump is out of office
but his awfulness lingers on
he's like a fart with bad hair
uh and i just
i just want to say to all you purists
on the left who could not bring yourself
to vote for hillary clinton because she
said super predator in 1996 enjoy
getting super pregnant in 2022
[Applause]
you